foreign
will face off against each other Evans
another guy who had a hard time staying
healthy last year in his 28 games immune to
the last season to Rivers Prospect in college
and Andre Markov for all those
years it was underrated excellent
Primo leaves that back
[Applause] and pull down with it
comes Matthew 9 drops it off that hard shot
short-handed by Minton has turned away by
Kaden Primo so he's kind of on an island here
he's got to play the pocket he strips it right
through London but he doesn't just tip it in he
makes sure he gets bow down to turn then goes
the back one of our run to the
conference final 99 and 0-2
00 on the power play here for
58 seconds to start this second
career this is one aspect of Montreal's
game that's going to have to get better
you can't coach goals necessarily the way you
can coach defense oh man drops that back to Watt
Joshua feeds that back go down but Pearson parked
in front Gallagher slides that back to boudin
Gallagher shoots those blocks and Threat by
Giordano boy he talked about drinking out of
a fire hose when he took the job in Toronto
you got to get the Austin Matthews extension
done you've got a arbitration case with Samson
off William nylander still unsigned not many
quiet days you know in that job but he came in
with the idea I don't want to change everything
because police have been pretty good I want to
change something quick shot that's what I'm save
and Parker Jones turned away in the doorstep
I'm on a hand what's that back from Meshach
to the Montreal Zone [Applause]
flogging things up at the Blue Line
Minton with the steal drops it back to
nice shoot scores this guy short-handed
Matthew nice a short-handed rocket
and Toronto takes a one-nothing lead
he's been impressive we know about the hands
and tight spaces and the the breach and the
physicality but I don't know about the shot
and I look at this from tops of the circle
catch release no real stream doesn't
tip off Odessa stick he just beats Primo
Fleet minus one on the night goes
back to work you're back out there
he shoots
here by Gregor understands Shore Cannon moves and
Primo kick that away he is fast and he will create
chances once all gets uncontested easy entries
coconut feeds that back out of the Montreal Zone
Harris kind of Knocked away scooped up by Gregor
back to coping and shoot to [__] punch scored
tipped in front of Toronto's
got a two-nothing lead
[Applause]
well I don't know if that touched anyone
from Toronto the way in I think it caught
a piece of a Montreal player good for check
by Holmberg turns it over McGregor with a
tight support and this catches that back
yeah you see the reaction in fact punches
over in frustration catching the shin pad
Noah Gregor picks up another Point yeah
he's going about his business doing his
thing grabs a point back across tonight
in the corner from Louisville got a nice
walk right into the shoots Primo to stop
Harris bumped there by nine
for two he's trying to take
that three back at the point
is Connor Timmons has a look
Wanda Robertson just lines out down up for
two he had skipped off his dick so much room
down the goal line for Toronto for Tuesday
back to Robertson fires Club saved by Primo
taking a nice little feed and you
know there's no screen here but
shot that you hope you can beat a goaltender
with not quite High Enough Primo snags it
Chief petrozelli gets into the Toronto
goal now his second appearance of the
preseason played 25 games with the Toronto
Marlies of the American League last year
also played seven games with Newfoundland of
the ECHL and of course the goaltenders you
want them playing so a better replace
a ball hat backing up in the American
League Roxette back to vertuzia Toronto
begins his third period on the power play
able to hold it for a moment now kicked out by
Jake Evans goes back down to petrozelli six foot
five goaltender from River of Massachusetts four
shot for Toronto not power play in comes Nye for
him Odell a one-handed shot and Primo makes a save
on that this might be it like you might this might
be the last period some of you guys are gonna
get to play for the Montreal Canadians in this
training camp so go give me something right like
like bump into someone show me some passion show
me some energy I I get it hard and like Lord knows
I've played plenty of times and people could have
looked at my game like we can do some Packers but
but it's been so flat you just want more well kick
the doors make me make a decision it's easy right
now breaking back three on two camp along with
Gregor can't shoot on the goal post I don't know
that's what I playing against you as we see David
Camp catch a deflection off the bar Kane green was
already beat up once from his own guy almost twice
so obviously I struggle cord I was over face
off for the first period over five or something
Federal didn't score though Monahan to armia I
was picked off by Gregor stolen back by Monahan
strip Monahan centers at Anderson shoot scores
Montreal is down one [Music] [Applause]
knocks it off the stick and then flag is in
chips it away guys standing around late in
the ship Camp can't identify where his guy is and
Anderson waiting there for an easy one-timer laser
and the crowd alive knives trailer
to Timmins shoots off the pike Primo
down no Gallagher snaps that
pass to send rights to Evans
is just fantastic that was easy draws it wide
and he throws the sauce to space just lay it
out there for Timbers to skate into it was
that a double chord I think it was is that
crossbar then post that is man that's a couple
that have gone past Primo Jackie works at free
from Montreal back to Evans that shot just fly
by Evans abrazizi pack the other way for Toronto
Anderson from Monahan and
Lindstrom how to go into Pearson
that's a line held by Evans time winding
down you're having to the front of the
goal a chance with Gallagher Locked Away
by knives and time is fires and Toronto
wins it by a final score of 2-1 as Montreal
applies pressure late in the third period